au fronton de la mairie de saint-louis
le mot fraternité trouve son
prolongement sur le côté du bâtiment
derrière la porte de ce bureau
je veux faire entrer les politiques
toute la journée des hommes et des
femmes défilent après avoir expliqué ce
qui les amène à l'accueil
ils sont reçus par jocelyne qui joue ici
le rôle d'écrivain public lorsqu'il faut
rédiger une lettre remplir un document
qu'elle a de motivation ou par monsieur
mobile originaire d'anjouan
il parle toutes les langues des comores
leur joie n'est le grand comorien le
mahorais le malgache et l'anglais
accessoirement donc une des cartes et a
sonné à jacky laquelle ce matin a reçu
une lettre de la sécurité sociale et
elle ne sait pas ce qu'elle doit faire
c'est souvent des problèmes
d'incompréhension parfois les plus
fumants si c'est un grand émoi dans la
communauté
donc peut-être qu'ils allaient tous les
gars ce n'est sa panique lille donc
c'était une grand problème mais après on
a sonné la a précisé sous le bureau des
migrants a été créé pour ça c'est que
vous n'êtes pas rhône à lui vit à la
réunion depuis près de dix ans il ya
quelques jours il a rencontré le maire
et lui a parlé de l'action qu'il mène
avec les jeunes de son quartier comme
sur le mail avait dit que tu amènes
crocs au cv tout à la démotivation
donc moi je vais transmettre sa aoc est
d'accord sans emploi le jeune homme
espère un contrat en chantier
d'insertion qui l'a l'habitable d'aller
là et ils ont un petit groupe reso
planté tout franchement c
[Musique]
aussitôt dit aussitôt fait
ici on appelle bangaly à 20 avait des
bandas ici mais maintenant ces disparus
c'est un gars c'est l'avis de
l'habitation au traditionnel voilà un
fait coco avec la terre et où au fil des
ans la ravine qui borde le quartier
s'est transformé en véritable dépotoir
avant on était si c'était vraiment
bordel on peut pas s'asseoir là
tellement y avait des moustiques
alors c'est là qu'on a trouvé l'idée de
solidarité pour venir faire propre notre
quartier avancé tpu il y avait beaucoup
beaucoup d'effets pas des fibres ou des
machines à laver des des trucs
alors j'ai eu l'idée comme j'étais jeune
j'ai eu l'idée de planter des petits
trucs là pour les arrêter et ça passe
parce que quand vint vois ça là
maintenant là il arrêta
a plu j'ai été 7e quatre lentilles des
bananiers voilà c'est moi qui a planté
sa il ya même des tomates
quand vous voyez là alors ça c'est salle
henri ça va c'est lui qui m'encourageait
vraiment à venir flatté quand il pleut
les corps se voit alors un sens table
vraiment bien si un racisme à la réunion
je sais pas mais moi j'ai pas vu je sais
pas les autres mais comme lui ces
réunionnais on est tout le temps
ensemble je n'ai jamais entendu lui ou
alors la voie là et on est vraiment des
amis je vois comment ses propres à fin
c'était pas comme ça c'était pas comme
ça alors comme les jeunes y voit ça
maintenant son père de gt dimanche voilà
arrive alors une habitante du quartier
avertis de la présence de nos caméras
en fait la dame là c'est un président de
l'association c'est là demain les mamans
de tout le quartier qui est connue car
voilà aussitôt elle propose de réunir
les habitants du quartier du planty
locale juste attaqué la whey nourris ni
tout le monde et nous voit avec la
mairie si il donne toujours de naco pour
nettoyer pour vous êtes tandis que c'est
une toile mais on a fait un effort que
la mairie fonya zod lait pour bébé ou si
l'on met une belle
voilà c'est ça ce que j'ai comme ça ne
me dit houle et ça a était dedans
si le projet aboutit la petite
plantation d'haruna au milieu des
ordures de la ravine pourrait bien
devenir un trait d'union entre les
habitants du quartier la fin de la route
il a roulé à lot et à l'ofce ya les uns
des personnes composent le désir c'est
tout le monde met la main après ne sais
pas si on le fait c'est que c'est bon on
n'a plus de deux êtres
celui-ci que créole après pour les plus
cruels qui restent nous peut mettre la
main avec nous tout à la gema guère à
l'aise
[Musique]
l'après midi c'est un vieux monsieur qui
se présente au bureau d'accueil des
migrants de la mule
j'ai la photocopie la dent donc c'est
bon je vais vous le bureau est devenu au
fil du temps un lieu de rencontre où
chacun se connaît
voilà c'est le type étangs et se
réconforte c'est toi excuse moi ce qui
se passe le vieux monsieur explique
alors que sa femme a fait un avc qu'il
est seul à s'occuper d'elle et que la
caf s'apprête à lui couper les
allocations à cause d'une confusion sur
son âge c'est ça le problématique de
mayotte
lupe titre ils n ont qu une quantité
quand je vais voir un petit coup
d'avancé 1900 combien mais dans un
endroit et email à moi je pense l'homme
et 70 en avant en fait chez nous là on
n'avait pas des dates précises sont vous
demande quel âge a votre enfant vous
disiez à peupler on a fait quatre
récoltes des ambrits vad
donc on est chaque année on a une qui
est donc ce qui fait qu attend il a
vraiment aidé
avant on est confronté aussi les dents
déterminer l'âge et grâce à l'aide du
bureau des migrants le vieux monsieur
devrait rapidement recevoir l'allocation
vieillesse et une aide à domicile pour
sa femme malade
le ccsp courant pour va s'occuper de toi
d'accord toute façon on a vu que ta ta
ta femme est pour rien fait je comprends
ne faut pas être pas t'inquiéter
à voir
[Musique]